c'est un véritable parcours du
combattant c'est l'une des conséquences
de la fermeture de l'espace aérien les
difficultés à rapatrier les dépouilles
des victimes du coronavirus dans leur
pays d'origine
au sénégal par exemple les familles
doivent notamment faire face à des
complications administratives la
diaspora sénégalaise en france a même
créé un collectif en ce sens pour en
parler avec mon direct seydina oumar bah
c'est l'ex coordinateur du collectif
pour le rapatriement des sénégalais
décédé
ducobu 19 monsieur omar ba merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
à combien exactement s'élèvent les
dépouilles mortelles qui n'ont pas pu
être rapatrié au sénégal d'un jour le
nombre de compatriotes qui n'ont pas pu
être rapatrié au sénégal dans le monde
s'établit ca80 au dernier recensement
mais nous sommes parvenus à en
identifier une soixantaine parce qu' une
vingtaine ont été déjà enterré
consécutivement à la mesure de l'état du
sénégal d'interdire le rapatriement des
sénégalais baissier du comique donc des
familles qui n'ont pas pu attendre plus
longtemps avait décidé d'enterrer leurs
proches dans les pays où ils sont
décédés
donc on peut dire aujourd'hui une
soixantaine de corps restent dans le
monde à être rapatriée aux céréales donc
vous l'avez dit ce n'est pas forcément à
cause de la fermeture de l'espace aérien
et des vols aériens qui sont interdits
que les dépouilles ne sont pas rapatriés
c'est bien le sénégal qui ne veut pas
quel est dépouille mortuaire ceux
rapatriés dans le pays
effectivement et c'est l objet du
collectif qui a été mise en place et qui
aujourd'hui a accompli sa mission parce
que le l'état du sénégal a finalement
décidé de lever cette interdiction qui a
un autre sens ne reposait pas sur des
arguments sanitaires et scientifiques
nous avons suivi de montrer ça au fil
des semaines et des profils de semaine
parce que en fait la lutte a duré au
mois presque jour pour jour et l'état du
sénégal a décidé d'accepter que les
nouvelles est décédé du que vides dans
le monde puisse être amené dignement au
sénégal donc ce n'était pas lié à un
problème de trafic aérien c'était une
décision administrative de l'état du
sénégal et saas est venue compliquer
davantage la situation
parce que il y avait déjà le problème de
l'espace aérien il y avait déjà le
problème de la disponibilité des avions
auxquels est venu s'ajouter ce blocage
qui a été posée par l'état du sénégal
alors concrètement on apprend que
l'interdiction n'est plus un effectif
vous rencontrez quand même des problèmes
oui vous savez les lourdeurs
administratives ne baisse pas en
intensité en période de crise et
d'habitude on an'a des lourdeurs mais
elles sont encore plus prégnante
maintenant parce que l'espace aérien
commence tout à peine à s'ouvrir et même
si l'interdiction est levée les familles
certaines familles par exemple sont
confrontés à des problèmes financiers
pour rapatrier leurs corps parce qu'ils
sont restés plusieurs jours voire
plusieurs semaines à payer chaque jour
une somme regardez le report dont ils
sont on peut exemple sur le plan
financier
d'autres rencontrent des difficultés
pour trouver les carreaux des avions
pour amener leurs corps donc la
facilitation qui consiste à la levée de
la mesure n'a pas régler quelques
problèmes fondamentaux auxquels sont
confrontées les familles aujourd'hui
alors j'imagine mal heureusement que
sénégal n'est pas le seul pays concerné
est ce que vous êtes au courant de ce
qui se passe par exemple pour les autres
pays africains
oui nous avons été contactés par des des
amis maliens par exemple qui nous
demandaient comment nous étions parvenus
à amener l'état du sénégal à de
meilleurs sentiments
ils ont estimé que cette bataille ne
méritait d'être répercutées dans
plusieurs pays afin que les autorités
sachent que c'est le transport peut se
faire sans risque donc le sénégal fait
figure presque d'exception parce que
beaucoup de pays avaient arrêté ce
transport pour des raisons que nous
estimions ne pas être scientifique tout
simplement
mais le ne sommes au courant des
problèmes auxquels sont confrontés
d'autres pays africains et et nous
pensons que si l'état du sénégal a pu
lever cette mesure parce que nous avons
su convaincre les autorités de la
possibilité de ce transfert d'autres
pays pauvres en faire de même sans aucun
problème parce que il ya un protocole
strict à respecter
et s'il est respecté on ne voit pas
pourquoi les personnes décédées à
l'étranger ne peuvent pas reposer dans
leur pays d'origine
tout simplement parce que nous avons su
voir constater qu'en réalité c'était une
décision presque irrationnel lié au fait
que le gouvernement ne voulait sans
doute pas renforcé ou alimenter la
psychose
mais quand on prend une décision aussi
lourde de conséquences il faut pouvoir
justifier ça sur un plan compréhensible
et pouvoir l'expliquer
or l'état du sénégal n'a jamais su
expliquer pourquoi il avait pris ces
deux décisions sur le plan strictement
sanitaires et scientifiques
merci monsieur à said in à omar ba
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes l'ancien
coordinateur du collectif pour le
rapatriement des sénégalais décédé du
corps un navire russe merci d'avoir été
avec